what if bloodborne 2 was real what if
you could explore other lands in Dark
Souls
what other prosthetic tools could secure
have used what is beyond the broken
sixth art Stone of demon souls and what
did we think Eldon ring would be back
when we knew nothing these are the
questions posed by Soul Arts which is a
Tome containing hundreds of artworks by
over a hundred artists each with unique
short stories just waiting to be read no
matter what page you flip to I'm
confident that what you land on will be
something unique and thought-provoking
for example this story is called ocean
born and the artwork reveals a sort of
spiritual successor to bloodborne where
Hunters confront all sorts of Horrors
down in the depths of a vast
effervescent ocean this month only
soulards is 10 off so please consider
picking up a copy for yourself Link in
the description and thanks thank you for
watching